hey guys welcome to simply learns
youtube channel
today we will learn the loops in java in
this particular tutorial
we will understand the fundamentals of
control statements by using
while loop do while loop for loop
enhanced for loop and
nested for loop i hope i made myself
clear with the agenda
but before we begin make sure that you
have subscribed to our youtube channel
and
hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn
hello guys and let's get started with
today's topic
which is about understanding the loop
statements
in java so first of all understand why
do we need
loop statements so generally whenever
you are dealing with
some data structures in java which can
store multiple elements
for example we saw array which can store
multiple elements
string is also basically technically a
character array which is storing
multiple characters
so whenever you have these kind of data
structures where you have multiple
elements being stored in the same
then in that case you would like to have
a way to iterate or access all of the
elements
in a seamless fashion one of the ways is
to access them individually one by one
but that's too much of work that's too
much of code there has to be a simpler
way
of accessing all the elements one by one
if i want to
and that's where the majority of the use
cases
for using loops coming to picture now
java provides multiple
constructs to write loops in java there
is a
while loop there is a do while loop
there is a for loop
there is also an enhanced for loop and
in the previous versions of java
a use case of iterator was also very
popular so
there are multiple ways in which you can
actually
iterate over a collection and access all
the elements of the collection one by
one
and you can use it to multiple useful
cases for example if you have a huge
i of employee salary and you want to
give
bonus to each of the employees and add
the bonus to the salary
then you need to do this edition for all
the employees it would be nice
to have to return a while loop and the
while loop can automatically access all
the
employee salary one by one and keep
adding the
bonus to the salary this would be an
easier way to do this rather than
individually updating each employee
salary
and the first loop statement we are
going to understand
is a while loop so the syntax of while
loop is very straightforward
you write the y keyword you enter the
actual condition which will be
evaluating to a boolean true or false so
you write the expression which will be a
boolean expression
exactly similar to the conditions which
you
use to write in your if statements so
you write your condition which will
evaluate to either true or false
and then you write your statement and
these statements
will keep executing till the time this
particular expression
evaluates to true so generally the way
it works is that
it will enter the while block it will
evaluate the expression
if the expression becomes true then the
statements inside this particular while
block will be executed
and after the execution of the statement
it will again go back again evaluate the
expression we call them
steps basically so it will go to the
next step again evaluate the expression
if this again if this still holds true
it will again go inside
execute the statement move on to the
next step it will again go to the
evaluation so this this loop will
continue
to go till the time this condition will
hold true
if it still doesn't make sense for you
don't worry we will have a demo of it to
make you understand how to use
the while loops and maybe it's a good
idea to switch to the ide
and look at an example of it so i have
already created
while demo for it here it is it looks
very small and simple
but it will get to the point where we
can understand how and why
we will be using the while loops so i've
created a while demo class
i've added a public static void main
method here which is the entry point
i have declared a variable which is int
count equal to 1 so the count value is 1
right now
and then i'm writing a condition here
i'm saying while
count is less than 10 do this
so it will print the current value of
count and after that
i'm using the post increment unary
operator if you remember we covered this
in the previous sessions
what is the meaning of this it basically
will increment the value of count
by 1. this expression is is equivalent
to if i write it in this way
if i write count equal to count
plus 1 this is exactly the same as this
no difference
so this will have the same impact i will
just remove this line because we already
have
the count plus plus here so if we try to
understand this
we are basically incrementing the count
and then checking the condition again
so at first time it will be 1 less than
10
yes that is true it will go inside and
print the count value the current count
value which will be 1 and then it does
count plus plus so now the count value
becomes 2 it will again go back here
again check the condition
saying is 2 less than 10 yes that is
true so the while condition again
becomes true
it will again go inside this print the
current value of count
which is 2 then do count plus plus so it
will again increment the value of count
so the now the count value becomes 3
again go back here at condition and
saying is 3 less than 10
yes that is still true again come here
print the 3
again go here make count as 4 4 less
than 10
prints 4 again count plus plus count
becomes 5
and so on so forth it will keep doing
that till the value becomes 10.
so at a step when count plus plus
results in the count value being updated
to 10
it will go here and say is 10 less than
10 now that is not true
because 10 is equal to 10 but 10 is not
less than 10. so this condition will
become false
and it will exit of this while loop and
it will come here
and it will execute if there's if there
was anything written after the while
loop that will be executed so that's the
idea that you want to do something
till a particular condition holds true
then you can use the while loop
define your condition and execute the
statements
and try to do something which changes
the state of this condition here i am
changing the count so that every time
a new evaluation happens if i comment
this
this will result in an infinite loop
because
1 will always be less than 10 i will not
be incrementing the count here
and it will keep running forever it will
never stop it will just keep
printing one one one every time till
your computer
program runs out of the memory so always
remember not to
end up into an infinite loop that's
probably one of the biggest mistakes
any beginner programmer does so please
try to be aware of that particular
loophole not try to run an infinite loop
always try to write something in the
code block which can
change the state of the condition and
also make sure that that state condition
sometimes sometime should become false
you should also make sure that that all
that always becomes false because if i
do this if i do this
then this condition will always remain
true because it is already 1 then it
will become 0 then it will become minus
1
minus 2 minus 3 so and so forth but that
value of count will forever be less than
10
and again you will never be able to exit
this loop your program will be stuck in
this loop
till your program runs out of the memory
so always remember to write
a statement or a statement of execution
in your in your code block
which can change the state of the
condition which results
in some eventual time when this
condition becomes false
this condition has to become false
eventually otherwise you will never come
out of the loop
always remember that so if we run this
program now let's
observe the output so we can see here
this particular statement is printed for
1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 and that's it
after 9 the moment the count plus plus
resulted into the count value becoming
10
it checked that condition and then it
just came out of the loop
because 10 is not less than 10 and the
condition became false
so always do something inside your code
block which results
at least of one scenario where this
condition becomes false
and that is how you can use the while
loop now you can see this is a pretty
generic code and you can write any kind
of condition here
write any code you want to execute here
and then do something
to change the state of the condition as
well in a positive way in a way
which results this particular condition
to be false at some point of time
and then your while loop will run fine
so this is all i wanted to cover
in terms of the while loop hello guys
let's get started with today's topic
which is about how to use do while loops
so let's understand when do we need that
and how do you actually
use that let me switch to the java
documentation and
if i can find some syntax of it as well
yep so
as you can see here if i just highlight
this portion
this is how you actually write a do
while
statement block so you write do you
start a code block
you write some executable statements and
then after
the code block ends you write a while
expression and end it with semicolon
this is the syntax basically
it starts with do or curly braces some
executable statements
a while block or a while statement
basically with an expression
ending with a semicolon let's understand
this with the help of a program to
understand the structure better so for
this i have created
a sample program here which is called do
while demo
again having a public static void main
method and it has a variable
which is count and it is initialized as
1. then i write do i write this
code block or the curly braces and then
i am just printing the value of count
then i am incrementing the value of
count
and then i am writing a condition which
says while
count is less than 10 and semicolon if
you compare this with the previous demo
we ran
if i just put them side by side we had
while condition
statement and the state change condition
here we have do statement condition
change statement
and then we check the condition at the
end so the idea is
that if you have a use case where
before you even evaluate the condition
you want to print something
even before you evaluate the condition
if you want to do something
in that case you will use the do while
loop
even before the while actual while loop
starts
if you want to execute a statement you
will use
do while loop for example if you want to
print the initial value of the count
even before the condition checks then
you can use do while loop
if that is not your use case you can use
a simple while loop
which is just described here in this
program so coming back to the do while
so i say do and then i'm saying print
this particular statement without
checking anything
this condition will be executed for the
first time without
any condition check at all this will
just work as is
like a normal java statement after that
i'm incrementing the value of the count
and then i'm checking the condition so
remember when this particular condition
is being checked
the first increment has already happened
but in the while case
we did the comparison before even the
first increment
the first comparison happened with the
original value of count
but here the first comparison is
happening with the incremented value of
the count
hope you get the difference in a better
context now that you will use this
when you want to do some write some
initialization code
before you actually hit the condition so
this condition will be
evaluated with 2 less than 10 and then
the value will be printed
let's print this example and we'll also
try to play around with this example a
bit more
to bring to build our understanding
better if i run this program
there is no difference in output if you
compare this with the previous program
we
ran for the while so it prints the count
value
so this is coming here then it
increments the value
then it checks the condition saying is 2
less than 10
yes that holds true if that holds true
it will go back to statement number 9
again print this again do an increment
on the count
and again check the condition with the
updated value of the count which will
say
3 less than 10 now similarly print the
value
increment check this will continue to
happen
till this particular condition becomes
false and once this condition is false
it will exit out of this whole do while
loop and it will go to the line number
12 and if you have any statement written
there
you can that statement will be executed
in this case
so let's try to change some values here
and let's see if
if we can make sense of this program if
we change the value
let's say if i put 11 here what will
happen now
let's run this program you will see the
now you will see
that this particular output is displayed
which says count is 11.
so what happened here that count was 11
it
entered the do while block it went to
this particular statement
which said count is 11 then it
incremented the value so the value
became
12 and obviously 12 is not less than 10
so it did not print it again it only
printed once even if the first time the
condition was checked
the first condition execution itself
resulted in false
still line number 9 got successfully
printed and that's the whole
that's the whole idea behind using the
do while
what if i change this value to 10 let's
see what happens
and after that we'll run one more
combination to just make it more
interesting
this time again count is 10 line number
10 will be printed as count is 10
then at line number 10 the count is
incremented to 11
and 11 is not less than 10 so in this
case
the loop ends and it will move out now
what happens if i do this
if i say less than equal to here let's
run this program and interpret the
output
now again only one statement is printed
because in this case
the count is 10 10 is printed here and
we are saying
10 plus 1 11 11 is still not less than
equal to 10 and that's why the loop just
exits
let's make it 9 and see what happens now
you see two values
so count is 9 it enters the do while
loop
goes to statement number 9 prints the
current value of count which is 9
then increments the value to 10 then at
line number 11
this while statement is executed and the
condition is checked
is 10 less than equal to 10 yes 10 is
not less than
but 10 is equal to 10 so this condition
will hold true
it will go back here print count is 10
make count 11
again check the condition is 11 less
than equal to 10
no it's not and then the condition will
return to false and
loop will be exited so hope this will
give you a better understanding now
since we ran different permutations and
combinations of the values
and we saw when this will be executed
and when this will not be executed
but the bottom line is very
straightforward that whenever
you want to write some pre-processing
logic
even before checking the very first
condition of your loop
then in that case you will be using a do
while loop otherwise
a normal while loop or a for loop will
absolutely work fine
hello guys let's get started with
today's topic
which is about for loops in java
so so far we covered about while loops
and do-while loops
and we also saw different examples of
using different types of data structures
like arrays but one of the core
requirements
whenever you are working with any kind
of collection
is to iterate over it exactly similar to
what i explained in the do while and
while lectures
that you would often require to iterate
over
a collection or a data structure and for
that one of the
most sophisticated and easiest way to do
that is using for loops
so let's understand the syntax of for
loop first
and then we will also look at an example
of it in the in the eclipse ide
so i have just opened the official java
docs here so if you see
this is basically the syntax of
a for loop statement so let's understand
it and let's also try to compare it
with a while loop so that we can
understand how it compares with the
while loop
so if we see the syntax we first see the
term initialization
then we see the term termination and
then we see the term
called increment now if i try to compare
it with a while loop
there also you basically did these three
things
you first initialized a variable outside
the while loop which is called
initialization
and then you wrote a condition which is
your termination condition
you wrote a condition saying let's say
while i is greater than 10 or while i
is less than 10. so that is the
condition which is also the termination
statement
the loop will continue to execute till
that
condition evaluates to false
and that's when the loop terminates
that's why we call it as
termination and then the third piece of
it is the increment
the i plus plus which we used to do in
the while loops
so these three portions together make or
constitute
any kind of loop in any kind of
programming language
and for loop if you see the the kind of
code which you
use to write in a while loop in multiple
lines where you first initialize
a variable then you write a condition in
the while block
and then inside the while block you use
to increment the variable
all of that can be done in a single line
in the for loop
and that's why i said it is the most
sophisticated and easiest way
to write loops in java so you write all
of these three things
the initialization the condition and the
increment or decrement
values in the single line and then you
start with the curly braces
and you write the code which you want to
keep executing
till the condition evaluates to false
that's the basic syntax of it so let us
try to understand this with the help of
an example
so here i have opened a class which is
called for demo and this is a class
which will demonstrate the usage of a
for loop
so again we have a public static
voidbain method which you can see here
which is the entry point and then i use
the keyword for
i put standard braces for the brackets
and then i do the initialization so this
part
is the initialization part you
initialize the variable
so i just say in try equal to 1
initialization done
you end it with a semicolon so that it
is a single statement
understood by java and then you write
this condition
which is your evaluation slash
termination condition
so this condition is basically the the
deciding factor
of how long your loops should run it's
exactly similar to what you used to
write in the while block
if i just show you the example this is
what we used to do so we did the
initialization at line number seven
then we wrote this termination condition
inside the while
uh syntax or the construct and then we
did the
increment here so we are doing all of
these three steps
but we are doing it in a single line so
this is the condition
and then we write our increment or
decrement values which are going to
change the
evaluation condition every time at every
step so we are saying i
plus plus so technically what i am
saying here
is that start with i equal to 1 and
then check the condition i less than 10
so
in the in the first step it will be
checking if 1 is less than 10
if the condition holds true go inside
the for loop
execute the statement at line number 7
and then go back
to this particular statement so we do y
plus plus so i
becomes 2 and then you again go back to
the condition
and again you check if 2 is less than 10
yes it is
so again you go inside inside the for
loop and do whatever is written there
there can be multiple statements here
for now i have just written one
system.out.println
so that happens and once all the
execution is finished inside the block
it will again go back to the increment
does the increment
so 2 plus 1 becomes 3 again does the
evaluation
exec and if the if the condition holds
true it will again go inside
so this will continue this condition
checking
execution and increment will continue
till the time this condition holds true
the moment this condition becomes false
the control will come
out at line number nine so that's the
basic anatomy
and control flow it's very important to
understand the control flow of a for
loop
otherwise you might end up into a
program which is forever running
and which will just eat up all the
memory available
in your jvm so be very sure of what you
write in your for loop
be very sure of specially these two
parts
the condition and the increment or
decrement
so this is very important piece the
initialization happens only once
and then this condition evaluates if the
condition holds to true
some code executes goes back to the
changing statement which can be an
increment to decrement whatever
and again compares the updated value
with the condition
so this will keep happening let's run
this code to interpret the output
so i will right click go to run as java
application
and if i interpret the output here
i can see that it started with count is
one
two three four five six seven eight and
nine
it stopped at nine so what happened
there let's try to
evaluate the termination condition so
let's say i
has become 9 and 9 is less than 10 so it
goes inside
and it prints count is 9 which is i
then it goes here and it says 9 plus 1
i plus plus means 9 plus 1 the current
value of i plus 1
it becomes 10 and then it again compares
the condition
so now 10 is not less than 10
10 is equal to 10 but it is not less
than 10 so the condition becomes false
and count is 10 is never printed because
this condition has become false it will
jump out
so let's say if i do this if i put an
equal to here
and if i now execute the same program
this time i will see 10 here and because
i have said that okay
check the condition if 10 is less than
equal to 10 that will become true
it will print count is 10 then it will
increment and the count will become 11
the i will become 11
and then it will check 11 is less than
equal to 10 no it is not
so condition becomes false and the
control comes out of the loop so that's
how you should
always try to interpret the loops you
can also run some infinite loops for
example
if i say i equal to 1 i leave it that
and i say i minus minus
so what happens i equal to 1 1 is less
than 10
yes it goes here prints the value and
then i decrement the value i don't
increment the value i decrement the
value so whatever value comes out
will always be less than 10 and this
loop will run forever
for fun let's try to run this and i will
i will have to kill this program
manually but just to show you what
happens
and what you should not do in your java
program so you see it will continuously
keep printing the values till
the program runs out of memory till it
eats up all the available memory
it is cut it is forever running it will
never stop because the condition will
never remain never never evaluate to
false
this condition will forever be true so
the loop will run forever
so i'm just gonna kill the program but
this is something which you should avoid
whenever you are writing java code and
this happens quite often
with beginner programmers hello guys and
let's get started
with enhanced for loops in java we
generally use the enhanced for loops
for scenarios whenever we have to
iterate over
a collection of items or an array of
items
those are the most popular and common
use cases
of using enhanced for loop and this for
loop
is even simpler like i said it's even
simpler than
writing a classic for loop and the
syntax is
simply like this you again start with
four put the standard brackets
and then let's start from the right most
because then i will be able to explain
it better
you specify the collection in the right
most side of the bracket
the collection can be an array it can be
a list
can be a map so whatever different kind
of collections which are available in
java
and we are going to cover collections in
detail so don't worry if you don't
understand what
our lists and what our maps and what are
sets we will go into detail
of each of these one by one in the
upcoming sessions
but the idea is that you put the
collection to the rightmost
then you put a colon and then you put a
representation
of the member of this collection so for
example
here this numbers is basically an int
array so this int array means
that this array can only hold integer
numbers
and that's why we write int here because
this
array is only having integers
then we put any placeholder variable
name this can be anything you can even
write it as i
if you want to you can write it as
anything any variable name
which you want to write this is a
temporary variable so now this
code is going to execute in a manner
that it is going to iterate over this
array
one by one starting from the first
element
going till the last element you don't
need to
write any initialization code you don't
need to write any
termination condition code and you don't
need to write
any increment or decrement code also and
how these threes
how these three values are actually
taken care of let's understand that as
well
so when we talk about the initialization
as
i have put an array here a data
structure here
the automatic initialization index is
going to be
the first index so when we do the
iteration when this for loop is going to
execute
it is automatically going to initialize
a temporary variable
with the value at the first index which
is the
index 0 as you know that array is a 0
index based
structure then comes the condition part
so the condition evaluation is going to
be
again based on the size of the array or
the size of the data structure which you
are using
it is going to start from the first
index which is the index
0 and it is going to iterate
till the array's last element is reached
so technically start from the index 0
and go till the last element that's your
evaluation condition and then comes the
increment part so at
each step after it has successfully
accessed the first element automatically
the index is going to be updated to
pointing to the next element
so if it starts from here once the first
step iteration is complete
i is automatically going to be
incremented to
index 1 and then it will basically
this i will be holding 2 then in the
next iteration
the same i is going to be holding three
similarly
i will keep holding the new value of
the collection item one by one till the
collection items
last element is reached so this is the
basic premise
that you can write a collection variable
here
and keep iterating over it and this
whatever
variable you write here will hold the
current item's value one by one so in
the first step this i is going to hold
one
in the second step this is going to hold
two in the third step
this i is going to hold three and so on
so forth that's the basic idea
so now let's run this program to see
what kind of output do we get
so you can see we basically are able to
print
all the elements of the array and that's
probably one of the most popular usage
as well
that if you want to just print all the
elements or access all the elements of
array or a collection one by one then
just use enhanced for loop
so you can see at each step it is
printing the value of i
and the value of i is basically the
subsequent elements of the array that's
the whole idea
with enhanced for loop under the hoods
if you talk about how does it work under
the hood
it is actually using the classic for
loop construct itself
but for developers it is making it
easier
because it knows that if you are
iterating over a collection
you will start with the first element
and you will go till the last element
so it knows the initialization value the
termination
condition and it also knows the
increment condition and that's the
reason you will use
enhanced for loops in java for iterating
over
collections hello guys let's get started
with nested for loops
in java so in front of you you can see
an example which i have prepared
for nested for loops and in this
particular example
i have created a two dimensional array
as you can see on the line number six
i have created an integer array and i
have put two square brackets here
which are basically symbolizing that
this is a two dimensional
array so this two dimensional array
is going to hold technically a 2d matrix
and we are going to use the concept of
nested for loops
to print this 2d array in a 2d matrix
style where you will be able to see the
rows and columns clearly
let's first try to interpret this
particular
2d array so we have a curly braces
outside
and then we have these three inner
elements which symbolizes three rows
basically
so this is the first row this is the
second row and this is the third row
and then each of the rows have three
elements each
which symbolizes the column values or
the item values
so it's basically a 3 into 3 2d array
which has 3 rows and 3 columns so
so we can say that this is basically
a 3 into 3 array which has 3 dimensions
on the row side and three dimensions
on the column side or just a three by
three matrix or three by three
2d array so as we know that in case of
arrays
everything starts from zero so
technically if we talk about the indexes
it would be the index 0 index 1 and
index 2
on the row side and similarly index 0
index 1 and index 2 on the column side
so that's that's something which you
should remember because we are going to
use this particular concept
when we write the for loop so let us try
to write the for loop now
if you look at line number 8 we put this
keyword called for
and then we write the initialization so
we say int i
equal to 0 then we are writing the
termination condition
and we are saying run this particular
loop
run this whole loop which ends at line
13
till i is less than 3 and keep
incrementing i
at every step that's what i am doing in
the line number eight
then inside the for loop i'm writing
another for loop
which has another different variable
called j it can be
anything you can name it anything you
want and this also starts with zero
and this also has a similar condition
which is which says
run this particular loop the line 10
basically
or this loop which is signified by this
curly braces
run this particular loop till the time
the value of j
is less than 3 and keep incrementing j
at every step and at line number 10
print the element of array which has
the current value of i and the current
value of
j these are basically the positions
these are not the elements
the element would be represented by this
hole but print the element
which is at current i and j's
position values that's what this code
means
so let's try to do a dry run on this
particular code to understand how this
is going to work
so at first we have i equal to 0 0 is
less than 3
and it goes inside it initializes j as
well
with 0 and j is 0 is also less than 3
so this condition went true that's why
we went to line number nine
and line number nine condition also went
to true
so we went to line number ten remember
that
in this particular case at line number
ten the values of i
and j are 0 and 0 respectively and we
are saying
print the array of 0 and 0. so 0 with
rows
0th column element should be printed so
this is the zeroth row
because this is the first first sub
block and
this is the first element so in this
case
in line number 10 2 should get printed
then it goes here
and it increments the j to 1 so 0 plus 1
becomes 1
it again checks the condition is one
less than three
so yes one is less than three it goes
here
remember it did not go up at line number
eight it just came back from line number
nine
so when it comes here i is still zero
but j has moved from zero to one so now
we are trying to access the element
which is at zeroth row first column
which is going to be
seven so seven is going to get printed
similarly on the next iteration
j is going to get incremented from 1 to
2
and again the condition will be
evaluated so 2 is less than 3
all good it will again come back to line
number 10
and now it will say print the value of 0
row
3rd or the second column or the third
element
so zeroth row third element which is the
nine
so nine will get printed then again j
will be incremented
and j will become three two plus one
three and now the condition will be
evaluated
is three less than 3 no it is not less
than 3 the condition becomes false
so it breaks out of the loop goes to
line number 12
prints an empty line because we are not
writing anything here so it will just
print a blank line
and now it will go back to line number
eight's condition
and it will do an increment of i and now
i will move from zero
to one and now the evaluation will
happen is one less than three
yes one is less than three so it will
again go to line number
nine again initialize j with a fresh
zero
the previous j got destroyed the moment
you came out of the loop
so this is a new j so this j again gets
initialized to zero
zero is less than three it goes here
remember i was 1
in this time so now it will print the
value of this 2d array
which is sitting at 1 comma 0
basically second row first element so
second row
first element which is 3 again j is
going to get incremented
and it will become from zero to one so
one is less than three
yes it will again come here and it will
print the
value of the array which is sitting at
array of one comma 1
for row equal to 1 and column equal to 1
which will be 6. similarly j will get
incremented again
again 2 is less than 3 come back here
we'll print 1
then again we'll increment j j will
become 3
3 is less than 3 no it's false the
condition is false
so it jumps out of the loop goes to line
number 12
prints a blank line again goes back to
8 line number 8 increments i
and i now becomes 2 2 is less than 3
yes it will again go here initialize j
again with 0
and again does the same thing for the
row 2 and
column 0 1 2 and again it will come out
of the loop
this time again when it will go here the
value will become from 2 to 3
and 3 is not less than 3 so then it will
break out of the outer loop
so the idea is execute the inner loop
for every value of the outer loop
remember this line because that is how
you will be applying your knowledge of
nested for loops to be used in certain
condition
so whenever you have a scenario where
you have to
iterate over a collection based on a
certain value of another collection
then you can use nested for loops or you
have a scenario where you have to
iterate over
2d or 3d arrays for example if we were
dealing with 3d arrays
then you would have seen three nested
for loops here and where it will apply
the same logic
that iterate over all the collections
all the values of the inner loop
on our particular value of the outer
loop then increment the value of the
outer loop and do the same thing again
iterate over all the values of the inner
loop
based on a fixed value of the outer loop
so let's run this program and let's see
what kind of output do we get
so like i said our motive our target was
to
print this in a metric style and you can
see that it is printing in
it in a sort of a matrix representation
so the first row gets printed here
then the second row gets printed here
and then the third row gets printed here
if you try to decipher it it will work
exactly the same way
as i explained so i equal to 0
0 less than 3 condition becomes true
comes here
j equal to 0 j less than 3 condition
becomes true comes here
prints the array of 0 comma 0 which is 2
then prints the
array of 0 comma 1 which is 7 0 comma 2
which is 9
then j becomes 3 it breaks out of the
loop goes
up here i becomes from 0 to 1 1 is less
than 3
yes again comes here reinitializes a
fresh for loop
with a new j setting to zero and it will
it will print the array of one zero one
one one two
then similarly array of two zero two one
two two so that's basically what we are
doing
we are iterating we are picking the
first row and hydrating all elements of
it
pitching the second row hydrating all
elements over it
and so on and so forth you can do this
for any n-dimensional
kind of array or a collection and with
that we have come to an end of this
tutorial if you have any queries
regarding the topics covered in this
tutorial
then please feel free to ask them down
in the comment section below our 24 7
support team will be happy to resolve
all your queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here